foreign
very good afternoon this is dharmesh
Vaya I'm going to be presenting a talk a
bit of a different area under SRE and
it's called time for some chaos anyone
heard about this name
chaos engineering anyone good so uh
before that let me quickly introduce
myself I'm dharmesh Vaya I work as a
senior Enterprise architect at VMware I
am also a Google developer expert into
cloud and payments and I also happen to
run the Mumbai Cloud Community chapter
so with that let's get started with this
talk
and uh yeah this is what we are going to
cover in this talk today a brief primer
around chaos engineering and what does
it actually mean when you say chaos
engineering right what are the
principles for that what are the tools
available and what are certain uh you
know Hands-On examples that you can do
it with it and some best practices to
share and leave it for you at the end so
with that let's get started for today's
session and which starts with something
oops
um
is there a blooper uh sorry this was a
blooper which we all might have seen
somewhere it's like a Windows blue
screen and we all have come across this
right so uh we we all know right like
when this happens your machine has gone
for a toss and you might not really have
figured out like how to recover back now
this is actually your uh I mean why I'm
bringing up this slide right I'm wanting
to reinforce the concept of resiliency
for you all okay so when I say
resiliency or resilience for that matter
resilience is actually your ability to
kind of bounce back now I'm not going to
read this textbook definition it's for
your reference but it's it's your
ability to kind of bounce back on cases
of any kind of disaster incidents and so
on now uh the same applies to Cloud
platforms as well when it comes to Cloud
platforms it is again the ability of the
systems if they go down how fast do they
come back how fast do they recover what
is the loss of data that they might have
made and like that is that is basically
without losing their operational
principles or operational capabilities
so that's exactly what you mean by
resilience when it comes to Cloud
platforms now
let me let me share some stats with you
does anyone know what uh does the
average cost of infra failures look like
now we all have been using managed
Services uh from either gcp or any other
Cloud platforms does anyone know what
can be the probable cost around any
infra failures
okay so it's it's almost like a hundred
thousand uh dollars per hour okay and if
this you kind of amplify it further
infra failures would lead to critical
application failures and this goes up to
almost like 5x this cost which is more
than that and it's like almost 500k to a
million dollars per R so now that's
really a huge cost as such when it comes
to any kind of failures and you don't
want this cost to be burning your
budgets as such so what is the solution
so it's it's the best approach uh is is
that like how do you make your apps more
resilient now that's that's one of the
foundational aspects around site
reliability or if you even talk about
side reliability engineering SRE
principles it's all based on the factors
around resiliency and reliability right
now
if uh and I'm talking uh further around
the cloud native applications right what
are the layers or point of failures that
you can think of when it comes to uh you
know failures so your app is just that
top of that pyramid and it actually
resides on a humongous layer of services
infrastructure platform let's let's
quickly see what are these looking like
so these can be like immediately
residing upon something called other
application dependencies it can be your
libraries
after that it can be any Cloud native
Services something like HTO Envoy
anything of that sort so it will then
come as the third layer then comes your
kubernetes services So that obviously is
your important layer and which is also a
point of failure I would say then comes
your platform Services which is where
your actual compute storage Network
would actually reside which is your
Cloud platforms itself so it is your
entire infrastructure layer
yeah
now again just to reinforce now coming
back from that resiliency background now
if I want to say what is chaos
engineering so again I'm not telling
this is the solution but
it's it's actually a branch or a
disciplined approach of experimenting
with your systems so that you have ample
confidence in your infrastructure with
your applications to kind of operate
steadily and withstand any sort of
turbulent condition so so it's like as
much uh confidence you are building in
your system and that's what chaos
engineering is actually you can read
more about that in the principles of
chaos but yeah this is the textbook
definition and and I've highlighted
three words out here you experiment you
become more confident to handle
turbulent conditions and that's how like
experienced Pilots also go for right how
do they handle turbulent conditions or
turbulent weather they they gain it by
confidence and the more you are exposed
to Violent conditions or turbulent
conditions you get more uh prone to uh
becoming more confident
um so okay
chaos does not mean your world goes
upside down chaos it's just a term it's
not meant to be an upside down or making
your entire infra upside down don't just
go for a top-seater we don't uh you know
test anything out of the box it's it's
not about testing things carelessly it's
about breaking things with a purpose if
any anyone from a testing background or
any any from a QA background as well
this might be the next field for you
when it comes to Cloud right so if you
are kind of breaking things on purpose
but with a with a with a objective with
a goal this is chaos engineering for you
right
now if we go from from the principles of
chaos right now there are certain phases
now see as I mentioned it is more of a
disciplined approach now in any
disciplined approach it's a scientific
methodology that gets applied and with
this kind of methodology you need to
understand what are the phases or how do
you kind of bring in or inculcate this
discipline now uh there are certain
phases so in practice what what actually
happens with chaos is there are certain
phases to this so when you want to
understand what is my expected outcome
so this is the approach that you need to
follow so there are four principal
phases that need to be followed first is
the steady state which actually helps
you define what is going to be my infra
looking like or what is my Baseline
objective then comes the hypothesis it's
as good as any kind of experimentation
that you do now hypothesis is
establishing your uh baselines from the
fact that okay what should my
application or infra look like in cases
of failure so how should they behave
that's my hypothesis then comes the
experiment
and finally comes the verification stage
so these four stages it's as simple as
understanding or any scientific
experiment that you do right you want to
form some basis or some Theory to that
and this is exactly the steps that you
need to follow so uh and and yes of
course
the harder it is to disrupt your steady
state which means that your application
will become more resilient and you will
gain more confidence so that's why this
last line which I have written the
harder it is to disrupt your steady
state the better will be your
application so from your steady States
in a much much controlled manner in a
much much refined Manner and I'm sure
you will have better outcomes from the
results of chaos engineering
so let us first understand what is
steady state so as I as I mentioned
earlier right it's basically
establishing your prerequisites you need
to understand what ah what what do I
need to test what kind of failures am I
observing with my application or what
what is the business objective as such
this can also translate to the related
business objectives translated into
technical objectives so this can form
your steady state it can be as simple as
establishing what is the bare minimum
throughput latency CPU memory
utilization and so on so everything of
this becomes my basis of steady state
next comes the hypothesis which is my
behavior during failure so what if a
system fails what if my part goes down
what if my memory goes full how does
that behave how does the application
bounce back what is uh like how does the
application actually translate back into
these scenarios and how does it
gracefully recover that actually my
basis of the hypothesis now it can be
into all possibilities it can be infra
it can be application performance it can
be latency or it can be as simple as the
slos and the slis by your Cloud
providers or your service providers so
all these can be the basis of
establishing your hypothesis now why am
I emphasizing on these two facts
steady state and hypothesis because
again that's exactly the basis of the
third phase which is experiments now the
better variables you have for your
experiments obviously you are going to
perform those experiments in a much more
refined manner in a much much controlled
environment and your objectives would be
met so again if I say what are those
experiments these will be derived from
your uh your steady state and your
hypothesis but these will then be tied
into real world events what are those
catastrophic failures what what can kind
of failures can come it can be Hardware
failures it can be infra failures
when I say infra related to software
defined failure so if you you miss out
some variable namings or it can be
anything as such a CPU goes for it or
some memory goes for a toss everything
of this sort is actually considered
under infra failures when I say Hardware
it's actually related to power and you
know the entire network going down and
so on and the last but not least would
be application failures application
failures would be more functional in
nature but yes they can be considered a
part of the experiment itself it can be
a part of the functional test Cycles as
well
then finally obviously you verify
everything so now you had your steady
state you had your experiments you had
the hypothesis in place but then what do
you do out of all this okay you need
some Matrix to be established who who
doesn't like Matrix especially if you're
talking to any managers right they all
need Matrix okay you are doing Chaos
engineering why are you creating chaos
for me give me the Matrix give me the
results and tell me like what's what's
going to improve for me okay so need to
define those Matrix from the steady
state now this Matrix can be as simple
again I'm reiterating the facts that it
can be as simple as what is my threshold
going to look like if it is matching
from the experiments or if it is
matching from the hypothesis whether it
is going good or not and in certain
cases how accurate it it's it is from
the hypothesis also in certain cases you
can extrapolate the results as well for
example in in a particular condition
an application is behaving in an X
manner but let's say if the the infra is
improved to X or 3x it might improve
better so if you don't have the right
resources or the bandwidth to kind of uh
do a large scale testing you can
extrapolate to a certain extent and
that's that's pretty much fair in
certain cases of infrastructure
now to sum this all up the all the four
phases of chaos engineering what are
what is the end goal out of this how do
how does it all tie up or gel together
the fact that the overall
um you know reduction in downtime that
is my Prime objective when it comes to
the outcomes of chaos engineering so the
first one reduction in downtime giving
me more resiliency the second one
obviously tied to revenue loss okay
minimal Revenue loss see every infra
goes down no system is 99 or 100
accurate that's why even the cloud
providers you'll see they are either
five nines or four nine accurate okay
and every system is Bound for failure so
how do you kind of reduce that amount of
failure and tie it back to financials as
well so that when you kind of present
this to your higher management you you
kind of talk about numbers as well so
reduced Revenue loss the third one
and the most important one improving
user experience you all have seen
shopping carts which are kind of uh you
know failing due to some product not
available and you sometimes see a fancy
icon over there some dog or some cat
over there right it's it's kind of
improving the user experience out there
and it's it's not just a failure but a
better way of representing your failure
failures will happen but then without
your end users coming to know that
something has gone wrong in the back end
okay let it get fixed automatically by
that time I don't want to lose my user
so if you improve your user experience
during these failures okay I think that
will also add to the value of improving
the resiliency of your system and
finally with all this what I want to do
is improving the overall confidence in
my system so if I kind of achieve all
this I know my system is going to
perform well in certain objectives or in
certain scenarios which are catastrophic
in nature so that's that's basically
going to be the summation of all the
four phases which eventually give me
better confidence in my systems
now uh there are several platforms we
are into uh you know platform based
world I would say okay and we don't
build everything from ground up so there
is something which is readily available
for us and there are certain platforms
or tools and Frameworks you can call
them I'll just name a top viewer here
and then one of them will actually see
in a demo so the first one is called
chaos mesh the second one is chaos
monkey which is actually something where
it actually all started so a popular
streaming service started this whole
principle around chaos engineering and
this was the outcome of uh the whole
exercise so this is a popular one the
third one is Gremlin although it has an
open source Edition there is uh also and
and Enterprise Edition it's heavily used
in Enterprises as well the fourth one
which we'll also see in the demo it's
called litmus and and I really like this
name litmus it's actually your litmus
test and and it really resonates with
the scientific experimentation as well
uh and the last one is called Chaos
Blade uh these five are the most popular
ones and they are heavily used when it
comes to anyone trying out chaos
engineering but yes eventually it's it's
somewhere between these that you will
end up using uh when it comes to the uh
implementation of chaos engineering so
uh quickly running through litmus uh you
know it it's basically a cloud native
framework that will have uh let's it's
basically open source you can write your
own crds into that which means if you
have your templates written you have
your yamls you can just plug them in and
you know these can behave as uh you know
scenarios or tests for your chaos
engineering uh principles quickly
telling you what exactly is the control
plane looking like so you need not go
deep down into this but yes if you just
have to understand what are the basic
components so there is something called
a control plane and there is something
called an execution plane your control
plane is basically responsible for all
the authentication managing of the data
and the execution plane is basically
where all your tests would actually run
so this is where all the testing would
happen and then it will spit out results
and all
okay so from an experiment perspective
I'm not going to run through this in
depth okay uh but yes if you just
understand from an experiment
perspective you need a lot of parameters
you need to define a lot of scope
variables and then based on that your so
again this is a part of that same
principles which is hypothesis
experiments and then the verification
stage so what do you need to conduct an
experiment it's basically any any
specifications that you need to test out
that is something that will come over
here now ah let's pick three scenarios
so the first one being around any any
disaster which is related to compute
failure so what happens when a pod goes
down so so how do you kind of actually
test that so there are experiments which
are readily available in chaos hub from
litmus chaos and and it's basically
testing your resiliency from the
application side of things or from the
infra side of things that what will
happen in case of pod failure so how
does the application bounce back if a
pod goes down how does it kind of come
back and so on so it is going to
simulate that for you and then give you
an outcome saying that okay hey your pod
went down at this this time and by this
time the Pod also went up we kind of did
an auto scaling or did an auto
regeneration of the Pod and so on again
there is a whole workflow for this you
can kind of really see that which are my
targeted pods which pods do I need to
run my test on and where do I run these
tests so it can be within the
environment or outside the environment
so it I mean when I say within and
outside it means that you want to run
the test as an outsider or within the
same set of cluster or same set of PODS
you can do that so a similar scenario
which is in case of a network loss now
what would happen in case your
application actually or your pod
actually faces a network loss what would
happen in that case so it can be I mean
things can go for a toss right traffic
flows can be disrupted your services
will be disrupted so what is the
objective or what is the outcome that
would happen in this case so here it's
basically testing the resiliency from a
networking perspective it's not going to
touch the Pod your pod can be uh you
know the compute can be like heavily
overloaded even then the network can go
off I mean depends there can be multiple
scenarios again there's a huge workflow
for that and these are all readily
available you don't need to write a
single line of code for this experiments
are available pick them and run them
okay and finally uh we'll pick one
scenario around storage which is what if
your you know pods or the ephemeral
storage for your pod it can be either
ephemeral or the persistent either of
them what if either of them kind of gets
filled so this one actually simulates a
pod fill or rather a storage fill or a
disk fill and then it will simulate like
okay what happened now is your
application able to handle this failure
or not and then it will take corrective
measures by either like scaling or
throwing up appropriate error messages
and so on so here it's it's basically
filling up the storage and then telling
you that okay hey your pod is not able
to respond because your storage went
full okay and uh yeah we'll quickly see
a demo of the litmus platform can I have
uh switch over to the deck please
okay so this is how the litmus framework
kind of or the platform looks like uh
sorry okay this is what the litmus
platform looks like I have this is the
gcp console itself I have created a
cluster specifically for litmus and over
here you can see that there are
different uh you know scenarios
available so these scenarios are
basically either from a pod delete
perspective or a pod disk fill
perspective here uh it it's a just a UI
based dashboard and let me quickly show
you a recorded demo so here is a login
screen
and if you see from here okay so it has
all kinds of facilities like user
management and uh you know the access
control and all so what you need to do
is basically create a ready-made one
okay so this part is interesting where
you can see that the entire flow of your
experiment is kind of given over here so
here you can kind of rearrange whether
first you want to do a pot delete
whether you want to do a network test
and so on so this part is is more of a
graphical interface and in the end you
basically uh I mean it does take a while
it takes almost 15-20 minutes to even
simulate a pod delete but yes after this
you will come to know that yeah the
scenario is whether they have passed or
failed you kind of see that back into
the graphical State itself so here you
will come to know whether the Pod delete
worked fine what was the outcome you
will get a tabulated result and plus you
can send out notifications as well so uh
this is this is a very high level
introduction around the platform itself
and and you can try it out by yourself
as well so that is litmus chaos and you
can you can just create a cluster and
use that can I move back to my slides
please
okay okay so uh ending this with best
practices I'm sure like uh this
compressed 25 minutes you just got a
high level overview of what chaos
engineering means and where you can
apply them just a few quick pointers or
takeaways for you when it comes to best
practices so the first and foremost
thing always focus on your
infrastructure the more you kind of dig
into the different vulnerabilities or
point of failures from your infra you're
going to design better scenarios and
your chaos engineering would improve
eventually improving the confidence in
your system the second tie all your
hypothesis as much as possible to your
slis and slos provided by your cloud
provider or provided by any infra
provider because that is going to be a
benchmark that you are going to use
forever the third one and an important
one the more you practice I always take
this example of a pilot or a or a flight
Commander the more they fly the better
it is their confidence when it comes to
Flying aircrafts the same applies for
driving as well right the more you drive
the better is your confidence so try to
understand the impact of chaos from uh
you know by practicing more in different
scenarios different environments and I'm
sure you'll end up with better scenarios
of testing
the one continuous chaos now this is or
the fourth one rather uh it's it's a new
term uh just as cicd is happening uh the
world is also digressing into continuous
chaos which means that you can take
chaos into production as well and the
better uh I mean you can have it more in
a controlled environment so if you can
do that well and good if not that's also
okay so that's why the fifth point is
mentioned which is limiting collateral
damage when you do it in production
ensure that your primary services are
not under chaos or else you will end up
in chaos so ensure that you know you
have minimal uh collateral damage uh
fine tune your scenarios test something
which is not really very active or very
hot in the usage patterns and that
should actually solve a lot of worry for
you and you can have a broad confidence
in the entire system so with that I
would just end up on one note like we
all say that okay kubernetes is the
answer to my scaling problems that's uh
and then that's not the case we all know
that okay similarly chaos engineering is
also not the answer to resiliency it's a
more of a disciplined approach when it
comes to building confidence in your
systems and making your systems more
reliable and more resilient to any kind
of turbulent condition so again don't
take this as uh the final word in saying
that okay for anything to improve my
resiliency let's do chaos engineering
check your systems understand them
understand the business use cases and
then go for these kind of tools and
Frameworks so uh yeah that's all from my
side thank you so much this is dharmesh
Vaya thank you
foreign
[Music]